Reboots, reimaginings, the odd
behind-the-scenes spat: Actors
can be replaced between movies for any number of
reasons — and sometimes it goes very, very wrong.
In the early '90s, Michael Keaton
handed over the keys for Wayne Manor,
having portrayed Bruce Wayne in 1989's Batman
and its 1992 sequel Batman Returns. Reportedly,
Keaton refused to reprise the role in the
third film after reading the screenplay
and in the years since has pointed the blame
for his departure squarely at the writers.
Val Kilmer clearly didn't share Keaton's
misgivings. The Tombstone star accepted
the role as-is and went into the
film knowing he'd have to contend
with a famous cast of villains and a new director.
"Riddle me this, riddle me that,
who's afraid of the big black bat?"
In the end, Joel Schumacher shouldered a
lot of the blame for 1995's Batman Forever,
though his leading man didn't escape
criticism. Kilmer's performance was
described as "utterly lethargic" and
"god-awful," with a review published
by Film4 specifically calling out Keaton's
replacement as being simply "not up to the job."
Many planned Superman projects failed to
come to fruition in the years after 1987's
resoundingly terrible Superman IV: The
Quest For Peace. Nearly 20 years later,
the Man of Steel returned to the big screen for
2006's Superman Returns. Director Bryan Singer's
take on DC's prized property proved to be a solid
enough platform to take the franchise forward,
though the vast budget meant that the movie
wasn't a financial success. That said,
Brandon Routh's turn as the Man
of Steel drew praise from many,
with Newsweek in particular gushing over Routh
for the way in which the newcomer "effortlessly
lays claim to the iconic role." The outlet even
favorably compared him to Christopher Reeve.
Although DC intended to produce a sequel to
Superman Returns, every year that passed made
it less likely to happen. Despite Routh
making it quite clear that he wanted to
don the red cape again, the studio opted
to reboot the franchise with Man of Steel,
a Zack Snyder reboot fronted by Henry Cavill.
Trouble is, Snyder's film took the aspect of
Superman Returns that people didn't like —
the morose, humorless tone — and amplified
it. Cavill's downbeat portrayal of the
titular hero has been criticized for
being too brooding and too dark, leading to a
Superman film that's practically devoid of joy.
Today, Back to the Future stands as
a timeless classic that continues to
delight audiences of all ages. Crispin Glover
played the role of Marty's father, George,
in arguably his most iconic role. From cowardly
creep to confident ladies' man, George undergoes
the most significant transformation in
the trilogy — both on and off camera.
In fact, some might not even realize that Glover
didn't return for Back to the Future Part II, in
which he was replaced by Jeffrey Weissman wearing
Glover-inspired prosthetics. Despite having fully
recast Jennifer Parker for the sequels, the
filmmakers opted to hide their new George McFly
via prosthetics and clever filmmaking techniques
that made it nearly impossible to spot the fake.
Originally, co-writer and co-producer Bob Gale
claimed that Glover quit due to a pay dispute,
but Glover himself has denied this on a number
of occasions. Instead, he says, he was removed
from the burgeoning franchise after voicing his
distaste for the ending of the original movie,
which he believed implied that the McFlys'
happiness was dependent on material wealth.
"Woah, this is heavy."
For Part II, the filmmakers spliced footage
of Glover's performance from the first film,
added new material with Weissman, and killed
off George McFly in the "alternate 1985" to
keep audiences from discovering
the truth. It worked well enough,
but upon rewatch it's clear how hard
director Robert Zemeckis tried to
hide the fact that Glover wasn't involved.
Perhaps unsurprisingly, Glover was less than
thrilled about his face being used without his
permission. Years later, he told the AV Club:
"They thought that was funny. They knew that they
could basically torment me, either financially or
by [...] what ultimately was an illegal thing to
do. I’m sure they laughed and joked about it."
Live-action Bruce Waynes tend to find a new
love interest in each installment of the Batman
franchise. From Kim Basinger's Vicki Vale to
Nicole Kidman's Dr. Chase Meridian, the Dark
Knight certainly gets around. But for Christopher
Nolan's visionary take on the character's origins,
a new bat-love was born. In 2005's Batman
Begins, Katie Holmes played Bruce Wayne's
childhood-friend-turned-love-interest
Rachel Dawes.
At the end of the film, Rachel tells Bruce that
they can only be together when Gotham City no
longer needs Batman, setting up an intriguing
arc for the two characters. However, Holmes quit
Nolan's Batman sequel in favor of the buddy comedy
Mad Money; she was replaced by Maggie Gyllenhaal
in The Dark Knight. No doubt, Gyllenhaal delivers
an excellent performance, and she certainly fits
the tone of the sequel, but it's hard to believe
that this Rachel is the same character as Holmes'.
Not only is Gyllenhaal's Rachel more
cavalier than her Begins counterpart,
but she doesn't seem as personally
invested in Bruce as she did before. Sure,
some of that is due to plot reasons — namely,
her romance with Harvey Dent — but it also may
be that Gyllenhaal simply didn't have the same
chemistry with Christian Bale as her predecessor.
Hugo Weaving's absence was sorely felt in
The Matrix Resurrections. That's not to say
that Jonathan Groff, who replaced Weaving
as the villainous program known as Smith,
is not a talented actor. Sadly, he had huge
shoes to fill: Even in Reloaded and Revolutions,
Weaving shines brightest among the cast, while
Ian Bliss tackles an inspired impersonation when
the character takes over a human host.
But the fourth time was not the charm.
"Mr. Anderson!"
"No…"
Considering Weaving's iconic turn as Smith,
a new version of the character needed to feel
either identical or significantly different from
the original in order to work. Unfortunately,
Groff's portrayal in Resurrections is neither.
Deemed "an algorithm of unoriginality" by the
Guardian, the fourth Matrix movie failed
to recapture what made the relationship
between Neo and Smith so special, and that's
due at least in part to Weaving's absence.
There was plenty of controversy surrounding
the making of the animated movie Scoob!,
a reboot feature meant to kickstart a new
theatrical Scooby-Doo franchise. Between
unceremoniously canceled sequels and the film's
failed attempt to launch a cinematic universe,
the biggest problem with Scoob! was its
casting. Despite retaining Frank Welker
as the iconic voice of Scooby-Doo, the
rest of the Mystery Inc. gang was scrapped
for this installment, including
Matthew Lillard's Shaggy Rogers.
Lillard garnered widespread acclaim when he played
Shaggy in the two live-action Scooby-Doo movies in
the early 2000s; he went on to take over vocal
duties from Casey Kasem for subsequent animated
movies and television productions. To this day,
Lillard still plays Shaggy as faithfully as ever,
but he missed out on the 2020 return to the
big screen. After the film's cast was revealed,
Lillard took to X, formerly
known as Twitter, to write:
"Well this sucks. What a crappy way
to find out…. thanks Hollywood."
Of course, Lillard wasn't the only
one replaced in the new movie,
nor was he the only one disappointed by the
news — but, given his many years playing Shaggy,
it was tough news nonetheless. And it
didn't help that Will Forte's Shaggy
just sounded like a higher-pitched Will
Forte rather than Shaggy. Thankfully,
Lillard has since resumed voicing
Shaggy in all other Scooby-Doo projects.
Some movies should never be remade. We don't need
another Citizen Kane, Casablanca, or Vertigo,
for example, and we certainly didn't need another
Psycho. What's worse is that director Gus Van Sant
chose to remake the film nearly shot-for-shot,
even copying some of Alfred Hitchcock's
signature camera movements. It's unsettling
to be sure — but maybe that was the point.
In any case, Anthony Perkins, who gave a
straight-up iconic performance in the 1960
original, can't be easily overshadowed.
So, when Vince Vaughn was cast as Norman
Bates in the remake, folks were understandably
skeptical. Given Vaughn's usual filmography,
his casting in Psycho made for something
a strange choice. As Roger Ebert wrote:
"He isn't odd enough. Norman's
early dialogue often ends in
a nervous laugh. [...] Vaughn's
laugh doesn't seem involuntary."
When all is said and done, Vaughn's Norman is
still a psycho, but he's a strange and unlayered
one at best, and not nearly as frightening as
Perkins' original. Like the rest of Van Sant's
Psycho remake, Vaughn's performance proves
the folly in trying to reinvent the wheel.
Can you believe that there have been no fewer than
six Home Alone movies? Obviously, the first two,
directed by Chris Columbus and starring Macaulay
Culkin, are the best by far. Over the years,
Home Alone and Lost In New York
have become Christmas classics,
while the other less-inventive sequels
simply rode the franchise's coattails.
"You guys give up, or are you thirsty for more?"
But though most of the sequels feature a
new protagonist in the place of young Kevin,
the direct-to-video Home Alone 4
opted to resurrect the original lead,
albeit without Culkin's involvement.
The fourth film takes place seemingly
a few years after Lost in New York,
with the McCallister family in complete disarray
— and not just because they've all been recast,
too. Here, Kevin is played by Mike Weinberg, who
isn't nearly as charismatic or lovable as Culkin,
though he does look younger. In fact, if the
character's name had been changed, you'd have no
clue that this was supposed to be the same kid.
No doubt, Culkin was looked over because Home
Alone 4 released 12 years after the original, but
that's no excuse. As the Radio Times review says:
"You have to wonder why they bothered."
Not only was Home Alone 4 destined to be a
train wreck after a poor third installment,
but trying to capitalize on the McCallister
family without utilizing any returning faces
turned out to be nothing short of a disaster.
Let's chalk it all up to real Kevin's bad dream.
Billy Dee Williams played a pre-disfigured version
of Harvey Dent in Tim Burton's 1989 Batman. Dent's
appearance was no doubt meant to tease the
character's on-screen future as Two-Face,
a turn he finally made in Batman Forever. But in
that film, it wasn't Williams facing off against
the Dark Knight, but Tommy Lee Jones. We all know
that Val Kilmer replaced Michael Keaton as Batman,
but many forget that Williams' Dent and Jones'
Two-Face are meant to be one and the same.
"Very few people are both a summer and
a winter, but you pull it off nicely."
Of course, there's a clear difference between the
two iterations of the character. Appearance aside,
Williams' Dent is a charismatic leader, hoping to
use his status to change the hearts and minds of
voters. On the contrary, Jones' Two-Face
isn't much more than a maniacal sidekick
to Jim Carrey's over-the-top Riddler, which
only makes Batman Forever feel all the more
outlandish. Roger Ebert may have once deemed
Forever better than Batman Returns, but the
movie's strange tone and misuse of Tommy Lee Jones
make it a controversial bat-flick to this day.
In 2021, DC Comics published a comic continuation
to Batman and Batman Returns that follows the
Michael Keaton incarnation of the Dark Knight.
Written by Batman screenwriter Sam Hamm,
the series revives Williams' version of Harvey
Dent and chronicles the character's troubled
turn into Two-Face, thus establishing the
events of Forever as an alternate timeline.
Tom Cruise brought the vampire Lestat de
Lioncourt to life in the film adaptation of
Anne Rice's novel Interview with the Vampire.
Cruise's memorable performance opposite Brad
Pitt and a young Kirsten Dunst is certainly
a highlight of the film — but did you know
there was a sequel? Cruise didn't reprise his
vampiric role, however, which is probably why
many people haven't heard of it. Instead, Stuart
Townsend took over for 2002's Queen of the Damned.
Also based on an Anne Rice novel, Queen of the
Damned was a complete and utter failure. Not only
did the movie tank at the box office, but Rice
wasn't particularly thrilled with it either, and
no other movies based on The Vampire Chronicles
have been released since. While Townsend may
have better resembled the character from the
novel in terms of physicality, he didn't have
the same sort of gravitas that Cruise brought to
the role. Film Threat's review of the movie read:
"Tom Cruise had the good sense to stay away
from reprising his role of Lestat in this
film. And audiences should demand this film be
buried never to see the light of day again."
Hugo Weaving wasn't the only actor replaced in
The Matrix Resurrections. Laurence Fishburne
played Morpheus in all three installments
of the original trilogy as well as the
in-canon Matrix Online video game, which
chronicled the character's death. Because
of his work in The Matrix, Fishburne
has become a Hollywood staple; he even
reunited with his former co-star Keanu Reeves
on multiple occasions in the John Wick series.
"At last."
Rather than keep Morpheus in the grave,
The Matrix Resurrections resurrects the
character, now played by Yahya Abdul-Mateen II.
"At last… Ah, wasn't too sure
about the callback. But, you know…"
Much like Agent Smith's recasting, Abdul-Mateen
makes a valiant attempt to bring Morpheus back to
life. This Morpheus isn't the original, but rather
a program meant to help Neo achieve his destiny,
which makes this red pill a little
easier to swallow. Nevertheless,
the lack of Fishburne no doubt contributed to the
critical and commercial failures of Resurrections.
Every Matrix sequel has proved that it's
nearly impossible to recapture what made
the original great — but at least the first two
follow-ups retained most of their original casts.
Compared to the first two James Cameron
films, it's understandable why most folks
dislike Terminator 3: Rise of the Machines. The
movie tries a bit too hard with the jokes and,
aside from John Connor's compelling character arc,
it doesn't really break any new ground. Still,
one of the strongest aspects of T3 is the budding
romance between John and a young Kate Brewster,
who learns all about Skynet, Terminators, and
Judgment Day just a day or so before it occurs.
"The end of the world… it's
today, three hours from now."
"Two hours and fifty-three minutes."
So when the movie ends and John
and Kate are trapped underground,
we're left to wonder… What's next?
Half a decade later, Terminator: Salvation
replaced Nick Stahl's John Connor with
Christian Bale and Claire Danes' Kate Brewster
with Bryce Dallas Howard. Compared to Danes,
Howard's portrayal is fairly one-note, though, to
be fair, she isn't given half as much to do as her
predecessor. Salvation barely even centers around
John Connor, let alone Kate, so it's no surprise
that Howard had little to work with. In a 2009
interview with CinemaBlend, the actor shared:
"The way that my character best
serviced the film was being kind
of an emotional sounding board for John Connor."
While the Mortal Kombat video games and animated
movies have done particularly well over the years,
translating such a stylized world into
live-action can prove difficult. So when
director Paul W.S. Anderson released his vision
in 1995, fans were surprisingly happy with the
results. The film starred Christopher Lambert as
Raiden, along with an ensemble cast that did a
decent job at bringing these characters to life.
Unfortunately, he didn't return in the sequel.
Years later, Lambert revealed that he
didn't like the script for Mortal Kombat:
Annihilation — and who can blame him?
Taking over as Raiden was James Remar,
who wasn't exactly notable in the role.
Although IGN later admitted that Remar
played the part well, the outlet couldn't get
past how bad the rest of the movie was, saying:
"Hilariously awful matte shots, cheap
costumes, obvious sets and some of the
worst CG ever put in a mainstream release
fill nearly every scene of this movie."
No doubt, Mortal Kombat: Annihilation is a total
train wreck, and, even though James Remar did his
best to make his part memorable, it only reminds
us of how terrible the rest of the movie is.
Halloweentown was one of the most beloved Disney
Channel features to hit TV screens. In fact,
it was so popular with '90s kids that two
sequels were made in the years following. But
then a darker installment came, following Marnie
Piper into her college years. Only this time, she
wasn't played by the lovable Kimberly J. Brown,
as Sara Paxton instead stepped into the role.
Return to Halloweentown was kind of a mess.
Though the majority of the original cast returned,
Paxton was the odd one out, playing an older
Marnie to whom viewers didn't recognize or relate.
Strangely, some House of Mouse witchcraft
must have been afoot, since there are two
conflicting accounts of why Brown was recast in
the first place. In 2010, Brown told Oct31st.org:
"I wanted to do the fourth one and was fully
available for the shoot. Disney decided not to
use me for the fourth one, [I] don't know why.
I was definitely disappointed not to do it."
But producer Sheri Singer had a different
story. In 2017, she told E! Online:
"It was not something we wanted to do. We couldn't
make the deal work. That was why
and we didn't want to not do it."
Sometimes, movies reference the fact
that a certain actor has been recast.
"Hey buddy, didn't expect to see you here."
"Look, it's me, I'm here,
deal with it. Let's move on."
Occasionally, a movie even takes
pains to explain the change in actor;
It could have been a dream, plastic surgery, or
some other strange off-screen development. And,
every now and again, they just straight-up
admit they couldn't afford the real deal.
That was the case with George of
the Jungle 2. In the first movie,
George was played by the ever-talented Brendan
Fraser. But, for Disney's direct-to-video sequel,
Christopher Showerman took over the titular role.
And the filmmakers weren't shy about admitting it:
"Me new George. Studio too
cheap to pay Brendan Fraser."
Of course, George isn't the only
character recast in the sequel:
Julie Benz replaced Leslie Mann as
Ursula Stanhope as well. Strangely,
Thomas Haden Church reprised his role as
Lyle Van de Groot from the first film,
though even his presence couldn't save this one.
If the direct-to-video budget didn't give it away,
George of the Jungle 2 is full of bad CGI, a
retread of the first film's plot, and, of course,
absolutely no Brendan Fraser in sight. In a review
from DVDVerdict, Showerman was described as a
"non-entity" who only serves as an "imitation
of Brendan Fraser's interpretation of George."
Nobody took over Keanu Reeves' role as Officer
Jack Traven from the '90s action classic Speed,
but The Lost Boys legend Jason Patric replaced
him as the male lead for its sequel, Speed 2:
Cruise Control. Reeves instead
chose to pursue other action roles,
which eventually led to the likes of Constantine
and John Wick. But with Reeves out for the count
and Patric stepping in as Officer Alex
Shaw, Speed 2 could only end in a wreck.
And wreck it did. Many cited Patric's
performance and the screenplay as some
of the film's biggest issues.
TIME magazine's review said:
"He's stalwart and athletic, but
fundamentally uninteresting."
Others, including original Speed star Sandra
Bullock, wished they could forget about Cruise
Control entirely. Interestingly, Reeves
is apparently open to returning as Jack
Traven one day. While promoting John Wick:
Chapter 4, Reeves told Access Hollywood that
a "great story and a great script" would
convince him to come back for Speed 3.
After the commercial success of the 1994
live-action adaptation of The Flintstones,
a sequel was certainly on the cards at Universal
Pictures. So when another live-action Flintstones,
titled The Flintstones in Viva Rock Vegas,
showed up in theaters six years later,
nobody was particularly surprised. The
first film had been panned by critics,
but the second — well, that was a real disaster.
"Yabba-dabba-doo!"
For starters, Viva Rock Vegas is
a prequel rather than a sequel,
and the movie recasts its comedic leads. The
original movie starred John Goodman as Fred,
Rick Moranis as Barney, Elizabeth Perkins
as Wilma, and Rosie O'Donnell as Betty. Viva
Rock Vegas starred Mark Addy as Fred, Stephen
Baldwin as Barney, Kristen Johnson as Wilma,
and Jane Krakowski as Betty. To say that any
of these actors are untalented on their own
would be untrue, but that doesn't mean
they were the right folks for the job.
While The Flintstones was no masterpiece itself,
the lack of comedic timing, uninspired jokes,
and lackluster cast of the sequel hardly
set it up for success. As Roger Ebert wrote:
"Minute by weary minute the movie wends its
weary way toward its joyless conclusion."
No wonder a third live-action
Flintstones has never materialized.
One of the few things that Terminator Genisys did
well was recreate the opening sequence from the
original James Cameron movie. From the de-aged
Arnold Schwarzenegger to the rebuilt sets,
the 1984 sequence is an exquisite duplication that
totally holds up to the original. Of
course, Genisys diverges from there,
with the biggest change being the lack
of '80s action icon Michael Biehn.
"Come with me if you wanna live."
While Emilia Clarke sort of resembles Linda
Hamilton's Sarah Connor, Jai Courtney looks
absolutely nothing like the Kyle Reese we're used
to. To its credit, 2009's Terminator Salvation
featured a younger version of the character, one
that still embodied the Kyle we all know and love.
"Come with me if you wanna live."
But Courtney, who lacks a certain
kind of charisma, doesn't translate
well at all. Unfortunately, Genisys was
already a mess and a half to begin with,
and a planned series of movies was quickly
canceled after the movie faced an increasingly
negative reception. Unsurprisingly, Kyle Reese
hasn't appeared in a Terminator movie since.
In the original X-Men films, team leader Scott
Summers was played by James Marsden. Though he was
written a bit too much like a jealous boyfriend
at times, Marsden did a decent job bringing this
Marvel hero to life, especially when it came to
his dynamic with Hugh Jackman's Wolverine. But by
the time X-Men: The Last Stand came around, the
actor had decided to star in Superman Returns,
forcing Cyclops' untimely demise. Thankfully,
once Wolverine fixed the timeline in X-Men:
Days of Future Past, Scott was resurrected,
giving us a new hope for his future.
And then he was recast. X-Men: Apocalypse,
the direct sequel to First Class and Days
of Future Past, introduced audiences to
a younger Scott Summers, one who has yet
to grow into the hero embodied by Marsden in
the original trilogy. Played by Tye Sheridan,
Cyclops is no longer the
field leader of the X-Men,
nor does he have much agency in a movie that
mostly centers on Xavier, Magneto, and Mystique.
Despite Sheridan's struggle to bring Cyclops to
life in Apocalypse and its sequel, Dark Phoenix,
James Marsden supported his successor, citing the
young actor's role in Mud as a particular
accomplishment. In 2015, he told HitFix:
"I think he's a wonderfully talented
actor. I think he's a perfect fit."
Few actors perfectly embody their comic book
counterparts quite like the cast of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe's Phase One. Robert Downey,
Jr. as Iron Man, Chris Evans as Captain America,
and Samuel L. Jackson as Nick Fury were certainly
inspired, as was Edward Norton as Bruce Banner,
aka the Incredible Hulk. Appearing as the angry
green giant in 2008's The Incredible Hulk,
Norton's portrayal of the runaway scientist felt
ripped from the original Marvel Comics themselves.
Not only was Norton able to deftly balance Bruce's
struggles with mental health and his desire for
impossible intimacy, but his Hulk was also fierce,
powerful, and best embodied the character's
rage. But then Norton exited the MCU, never to
return. In 2014, he told the Hollywood Reporter:
"My feeling was that I experimented and
experienced what I wanted to. I really,
really enjoyed it. And yet, I looked
at the balance of time in life that
one spends not only making those sorts of
films but then especially putting them out,
and the obligations that rightly come with that."
So, for 2012's grand team-up feature The Avengers,
Marvel recast Mark Ruffalo as Bruce Banner.
"That's my secret, Cap. I'm always angry."
Ruffalo has played the reluctant hero ever
since, but unfortunately, his more comedic
take on the character feels too far removed
from Norton's intricately complex dive into
Bruce Banner's psyche. In this case, at least, it
seems like the MCU opted for style over substance.